Prof: I'm going to talk
about some of my favorite people
today.
Over the weekend I was at a
memorial service and a
conference in honor of my late
mentor, the great historian and
sociologist, Charles Tilly.
When I first knew him,
which was a long time ago,
he was working on collective
violence.
He's someone in his career who
published literally fifty-one
books and over 600 articles,
but above all was a generous
mentor to a whole bunch of
people,
including yours truly.
He was working on collective
violence.
He once told me--in fact,
I couldn't find exactly where
he wrote this,
if he did--he once told me,
and I mentioned this the first
day,
"It's bitter hard to write
the history of remainders."
Some of the people I'm going to
talk about today didn't see
themselves as remainders in
history,
but they're people who didn't
quite fit in,
and were really overwhelmed and
ultimately defeated by the
economic, social,
and political processes.
If one of the themes of the
course and of any course,
really, I suppose,
that deals with the modern
world experience,
especially in this day of
globalization,
is the dynamic duo of
capitalism or large-scale
economic change and the state,
you're going to see that today
in some of the folks that I'm
talking about.
I once used the example of
trying to get you to imagine
parachuting over the European
continent over a very slow
descent.
Let's say now from maybe
mid-sixteenth century until
mid-nineteenth century.
If you could see every incident
of collective violence,
of political protest,
popular protest that
occurred--and all protest is
ultimately political--by far the
most prevalent would have been
the grain riot.
This itself is terribly
significant and so is its
disappearance,
given what I just said about
the state and large-scale
economic change.
Another way to imagine this is
if you had a Richter Scale that
moved or that registered every
incident of collective violence.
Tilly and his whole team were
counting up every single
incident of collective violence
that they could find in Europe
between mid-eighteenth century,
in terms of his study,
or even earlier than that,
and 1936.
They would come to the same
conclusion that you would,
were you floating over this
great continent for that period
of time.
What I'm going to do today is
sort of a trilogy,
talk about three things,
and they're all related.
First, grain riots.
Second the swing movement,
Captain Swing,
drawing on the classic book a
long time ago of Eric Hobsbawm
and George Rudé,
two truly great historians
along with Tilly.
Third, talk about something
that I did, the Demoiselles of
the Ariège,
and I'll make that clear in a
while.
All three fit together,
I think, very nicely.
One of the underlying themes,
which you'll see,
is that popular protest and
collective violence attached to
popular protest is not random.
It can be spontaneous,
but it's not illogical.
There's a logic to popular
protest right through the ages
in the early-modern period as
well as in the nineteenth
century,
and ordinary people put forth
their demands by protesting and,
in doing so,
hope to affect change,
to appeal to authorities who
hopefully will do the right
thing,
often imagining a world in the
past where a sense of justice
prevailed.
In terms of grain riots I'll
talk about the just price,
because they talked about it.
Having said that,
let me enter the world of grain
riots.
I'll give you some examples.
This is from Spain,
1856, with the pretext of the
high price of bread and for lack
of work.
The workers of Valladolid and
Burgos rose and burned flour
stores, mills,
and inspection offices.
The civil governor intervened
to put down the rising,
but the rebels overwhelmed him
and attacked the chiefs of his
forces.
The sacking and burning
continued.
Most likely,
as a consequence of the
spreading of news of the
incident, disturbances also
spread to the countryside and to
other cities.
The governor of Palencia tried
to hold back the uprising in his
city, but he had to retreat
before a hissing crowd.
In Benavente,
Rioseco, and along the Castille
Canal, the disorders recurred.
They had the characteristics of
the old type of rebellion aimed
at spectators and hoarders,
among whom the masters of
workshops were counted.
In their hatred,
the insurgents set fire to
shops and storehouses with the
cry of,
"cheap bread,
cheap bread,"
and attacked the boats that
served for the transport of
grain as well as putting the
torch to grain not yet harvested
in the fields.
If you back up almost a century
ago in France,
if you look at the memoirs of a
royal official from May 3,
1775: "The musketeers,
who had been warned the day
before,
hurried to the markets.
The fleeing rioters overturned
baskets full of bread and
blocked the way to the horses.
It was 9:00 a.m.
The watch was supposed to be
getting its orders at that hour
and the people had already gone
to the bakers and seized the
bread they found in the shops.
That pillage had a special
character.
People did it without violence.
The shops of the bakers were
emptied and those of the pastry
makers and the dealers and other
foods which were equally exposed
were left untouched."
Or 1816 in England,
East Anglia:
in early summer a surprise came
that the agricultural laborers
(who we will come back to hear
about in a little while) of East
Anglia had come out in revolt.
Conditions had worsened since
the end of the Napoleonic war
and riots and disturbances were
everywhere in the towns.
The point is that I could give
you examples from virtually
every country over a very long
period of time and the grain
riot would dominate.
This is France-based,
but it's true of almost
everywhere--again,
do not write this down--men
fight for food in the following
years particularly.
They come in waves,
1693-94,1698,
1709-10,
1728,1739-40,1749, 1752,
1768,1770,
1775 a big one,
1785,1788-89,1793,
1799,1811-12,181
6-17,1829-30,1839-40,
1846-47,1853-54,
and then never again.
By never again,
I mean in France never again
and slowly the grain riot
disappears as a form of
political protest,
of collective violence or
collective nonviolence,
depending on the case.
That's the big question.
What's going on here?
Popular protest is a way of
finding out what's going on when
you look at all this stuff.
Why do the grain riots
disappear as a form of
collective violence?
Why?
Here's a placard,
that is a poster,
scrawled in the town of Vaville
in the West of France in 1709.
"We are dying of hunger.
We must absolutely order you to
set prices on bread and grain or
else we will break from our
homes like enraged lions,
weapons in one hand,
fire in the other."
Arson--fire,
by the way, is one of those my
friend, Jim Scott at Yale,
calls weapons of the weak.
A match to a harvest or a roof
of a chaumière,
a thatched cottage,
can do some serious mischief.
What these grain rioters want
to do, very ordinary people,
men and particularly
women--remember,
women are responsible for the
household economy.
Also young people and also
children.
What they want to do is they're
putting forth claims.
They want the government,
the monarchies,
the administrators,
the officials,
the intendants,
the governors,
the sheriffs in England to set
the price of bread,
as Maximilien Robespierre and
the Jacobins had wanted them to.
Why?
To set the price of bread.
To keep the price of bread low
so that everybody would have
access to buying bread.
Bread--literally,
that commodity,
whether dark bread in the
poorer regions of central Europe
or in the south of France or in
parts of Spain and southern
Italy,
or white bread,
which is more associated with
more prosperous peasants,
represented more than half of
the expenses of ordinary people,
not just food but bread.
Bread is what people ate.
Black bread in the poorer areas;
white bread in the wealthier
areas, to make a generalization.
There were all different kinds
of bread.
Here's how I can approach this.
In the town of Liege,
which is in Wallonia,
that is in what's now eastern
Belgium, Liege,
famous for its cork among other
things,
and now part of the rust belt
of eastern Belgium,
they had a municipal statute,
that is a municipal regulation,
from about the fourteenth
century.
The date 1317 sticks in my mind
somewhere.
I must have read that decades
ago.
It said that on market day
merchants from other places
would not be allowed in to buy
grain until the third day of the
market.
By the way, the term for
merchants they used were
engrosseurs,
which has a sense in French of
a bunch of people who would make
themselves fat.
Why?
Because they could afford to
buy bread at the price that
nobody else could afford.
They wouldn't be allowed in
until the third day of the
market.
But, of course,
that's not what happens through
most of European history.
The pressure from these crowds,
the logic of these crowds is to
force municipal authorities in
the name of order--but perhaps,
who knows,
in the name of justice--to set
a price of bread so that
everybody could have a shot at
it.
As some wag once put,
criticizing this kind of social
history, "Well,
it's pretty obvious that grain
riots occur on market days in
areas in which there is grain
being exported out of a
region."
But that is precisely the point.
The peasants or townspeople
don't riot.
Ordinary people don't riot
necessarily when the price of
grain reaches its absolute
maximum.
When they riot,
they seize grain or they
pillage shops,
at the moment
when--particularly when they see
grain being taken out of the
community,
removed from their sense of
moral authority over something
upon which they depend to live.
Women, as I said before,
played the major role in grain
riots.
Why?
Because they're responsible for
the household economy.
Right through this whole period
there's a familiar scenario.
People pour into town for
market day.
They see the stagecoaches,
the diligences,
the wagons carting the grain
away and they stop it.
They stop it.
It's the same format everywhere.
It's as if you had some sort of
Internet, or CNN,
or something like that telling
people, "Here's how you
grain riot."
But they don't rip off the
grain and they don't rip off,
as the one example I gave you,
fancy pastries and stuff like
that.
They take the grain often to a
communal piece of property,
such as the commons or the
shed, the covered market.
Some of the most fantastic
examples are in the south of
France, but all sorts of places,
too.
They sell the grain to ordinary
people at what they consider to
be the just price.
They use that expression,
"the just price."
There's a sense of moral
outrage that some forces they
can't control are taking away
what they need to survive.
In 1789, a year you know,
what's the big collective
action in Paris?
It's the seizing of the
Bastille, of course,
but above all it's the attack
on the customs barriers,
the tax offices that ring
Paris,
which forced the price of food,
grain, bread,
everything up higher.
They attacked them as a symbol
of what they considered to be an
unfair economy that's depriving
them of the right to have enough
to eat.
So, these wagons that are
carrying grain away,
who's in these wagons?
Who are these folks and what
are they doing?
They're merchants and they know
that when they're buying up
grain, where are they taking it?
They're taking it to Berlin,
or Stuttgart,
or Munich, or to Milan,
or to Paris,
or to Lyon.
Why?
Because that grain will command
even a higher price there,
where you've got all these
people.
What is the interest of
monarchies and other forms of
tyranny, if you will?
It's their interest to feed the
cities first.
The growth of cities,
the growth of bureaucracies,
of the state,
the growth of garrisons who
have to be fed increases the
pressure on grain in times of
harvest failure.
Grain riots not only have the
timing of markets when grain is
leaving the town,
but obviously the subtext is
that in times of these cyclical
harvest failures.
The harvest fails.
Credit is withdrawn.
The price of bread goes up and
the riots start.
If you look at where the riots
start in any of these countries
that I've talked about,
it's in response to grain being
taken out of rural regions and
being taken to cities to get
higher prices.
You've got the merchant on the
wagon, too, and you've probably
got his driver.
Who else do you have there,
increasingly?
You've got the Guarda Civila in
Spain,
or you've got various police in
the Italian estates,
or you've got the tough,
hardened Berlin police,
or the Prussian army,
or you've got the
gendarmes or the
maréch
aussée,
as they called them in the
eighteenth century,
or the gendarmes in the
nineteenth century.
Here again is a way of looking
at this theme.
The state and capitalism are on
the wagon here.
You've got the merchant and
you've got the police guarding
him.
That's the dynamic duo of
change over the long run.
To be sure, people who have big
plots of land in Pomerania,
or in northern Italy,
or in the Beauce south of
Paris,
around Chartres,
or someplace like that,
these people are not out grain
rioting.
What are they doing?
They're hoarding.
They're waiting until the price
of grain even goes higher.
That's why a form of popular
protest, of collective action
throughout this whole period are
attacks on hoarders.
1789--you read about it in the
book.
The famine plot,
the idea that wealthy
aristocrats are trying to starve
out the poor to get their way
and that hoarders have huge,
just sacks of grain,
which they often did,
in their chateaus.
They're holding it from the
market and laissez faire says,
"Let the market decide the
price."
"Okay, let's keep that
stuff back.
People will go hungry.
Too damn bad for them.
They should have more
money."
Over and over and over again in
all of these places the grain
riot is the most important form
of collective violence,
of popular protest.
Then it just disappears.
Again, France is the most
studied, but it disappears
earlier in Britain.
You'll know why already.
You already know.
I'll tell you again in a minute.
There ain't no peasants left in
Britain.
In France, the last wave is
1855.
Now, there are protests at the
end of the nineteenth century
against the high cost of food.
One shouldn't imagine people
surrounding the Stop N Shop and
blocking it with their little
pushcarts that they're putting
their frozen food into,
but they're the equivalents of
that.
There are protests against the
high cost of food.
Food still is an important
dynamic in protests.
In World War II,
for example,
irritation about the rich doing
even better than ever,
and rationing cards and all
that business.
But the grain riot simply
disappears as a form of popular
protest in Europe,
period.
It doesn't mean that bread
wouldn't be terribly important
in the Russian Revolution.
It does.
There are riots in Russia
against the high price of bread.
But the classic beginning in
Western Europe and moving east,
the classic,
the quintessentially popular
domain of protest,
expression of popular protest
just disappears,
period,
point.
Why?
The battle's been won.
The merchants,
the police, the
gendarmes,
the troops, they're already
there.
Beginning again west to Eastern
Europe, you've got the
depopulation of marginal rural
property, marginal rural lands.
People can't make it anymore
producing little bits of this
and that and they plunge
themselves into the
ever-increasing urban world in
order to find work.
And, so, if you look at what
people protest over,
we can see this big economic
change.
The nineteenth century just
transforms the way people live.
This is for sure.
The nineteenth century didn't
invent consumer culture.
We already know,
Jan deVries has just published
within the last month or two
just a brilliant book showing
that ordinary families made all
sorts of sacrifices to try to
improve their lives beginning
the middle of the seventeenth
century,
participating in this consumer
culture, buying soap,
buying forks,
and that kind of thing.
But these big-time economic
changes, the nineteenth century
is the crucial period in the
whole thing.
The disappearance of the grain
riot as a form of popular
protest is a fantastic
demonstration of that fact.
You don't want to complicate
the thing or undermine the
validity of what I've said by
imagining, "Well,
that's all pre-modern,
this kind of protest.
Then we've got modern protest
and more strikes and all
that."
It's true that there are more
strikes and strikes become
another classic form of
political protest,
but the world of the nineteenth
century was changing.
The big losers in all of this
are rural people,
rural laborers,
peasants who simply couldn't
make a go of it and their world
was transformed.
That's part one of this trilogy.
Secondly, let's look at the
Swing Movement.
These next two things I'm going
to talk about take place really
at the same time.
That's not a coincidence.
It's not a coincidence at all.
The first story is that of
Captain Swing.
I alluded to this the very
first day, those of you who were
here.
It was in 1829-30.
Those are the big years.
The Demoiselles of the
Ariège comes at just the
same time.
They are similar and
fascinating.
I think they're fascinating.
I hope you will, too.
They have so much in common
with each other and with what
I've just been talking about.
It's not about winners and
losers in the brave new economy
of high-powered capitalism and
all its incarnations in Europe,
big and small.
We see the faces,
the remainders of this kind of
economic change.
Again, the people who worked on
Captain Swing were George
Rudé and Eric Hobsbawm.
How do I put this?
There was a real person called
Ned Ludd in about 1816-17 in
England.
The English word Luddite is
someone who's a machine breaker.
Luddism is machine breaking.
You break machines because
machines are putting you out of
work.
You're a handloom weaver.
There are famous cases in
Silesia in Germany.
Then machines for glassworks
and then later in the century,
things I talked about last
time, were putting them out of
work.
Ned Ludd busted up machines.
He broke machines.
1829 was an awful economic year
everywhere in Europe.
A freezing winter and real
hunger in Britain.
That's my example.
It's from Britain,
from England specifically,
from the south of England even
more specifically.
They found people who were
starved to death in the fields
with only dandelions in their
stomachs with nothing else to
eat.
If you were a Frenchman,
or a German,
or a northern Italian,
and you went to England in 1829
or 1830,
if you did the reverse of the
Arthur Young track--Arthur Young
was always wandering through
France and discovering people he
thought were sixty-five or
seventy.
It turned out they were
twenty-nine.
They were so battered and
beaten down by hardship.
There's famous case of a woman
he met in Champagne near Reims
of that case.
Arthur Young saw all of these
peasants in Europe,
but the counterpart of Arthur
Young, people from the continent
going to England,
were amazed.
There weren't any more
peasants, virtually no peasants.
You'd find a peasant as a small
property owner existentially
committed to the land,
that's a little bit overly
fancy,
but dependent upon a lopin
de terre,
a small piece of land,
for family survival,
the household economy.
There weren't any more peasants
left in England.
There were gentry,
including big property owners
who were masters of all that
they saw before them,
in the portraits they had
painted of themselves.
You had gentry.
You had yeomen who were sort of
smaller versions of gentry.
You had middle-rank property
owners and this sort of thing.
You had wealthy people from the
city wanting to live in an
aristocratic way buying as much
land as they could take.
There was no place in Europe in
which such a small percentage of
the population owned so much of
the land.
That's still true today in
Britain.
But there weren't any peasants.
Why?
Because the big fish had eaten
the smaller fish.
And because,
beginning in the sixteenth
century,
the enclosure movement,
which you've read about,
I think,
meant that basically,
no surprise,
the big guys get the law on
their side.
Parliament passes thousands of
acts of enclosure which allow
people to enclose and divide up
the common land.
The big fish eat the smaller
fish and the peasantry is
basically destroyed.
What you have,
as I said before in another
context, in England,
is you've got all sorts of
textile workers.
You've got all sorts of
governesses and domestic
workers, and you have hundreds
of thousands,
millions of agricultural
laborers.
You have agricultural laborers
in other countries,
too.
But you also have small
property owners.
There's hardly any of those
folks left in England.
To return to the story,
in 1829 ordinary people start
participating in protest and
collective action.
They start threatening,
and smashing,
and burning threshing machines.
Why threshing machines?
Because threshing machines are
taking their work.
The way they survive is during
harvest they go from place to
place working,
the way people still do in the
wine harvest in the south of
France,
working from place to place
bringing in the harvest,
prosperous agricultural land in
the south of England.
This is how they get by.
They don't live very well.
They don't do very well,
but they're lodged.
They're fed.
They have a crummy place to
sleep, but they can do okay.
Then the big guys,
the big farmers start buying
threshing machines.
The threshing machines do the
work of these people.
Next time they guys come along
in groups of ten,
twenty, thirty,
families, pals,
friends, they come around and
say, "It's harvest time.
Here we are.
Nous voilà."
"Sorry, ol' chap.
We don't need you.
Maybe a couple of you,
but we don't need you.
We've got these machines.
They do the job that you used
to do.
We don't have a problem with
them working hard all the time.
The machines work all the time
at our command.
See ya!"
Are they mad?
They're furious.
They start burning these
machines.
They start smashing down the
gates and going in and burning
these machines.
Then they started to find
posters that had been written,
scrawled posters,
sometimes barely literate,
because this wasn't a literate
population.
They begin to talk about a
mythical-like figure like Ned
Ludd, except this wasn't a real
one.
My favorite--I had this former
girlfriend a long time ago at
Mighty Michigan,
and we were going to write a
screenplay about this.
We never did.
One of them said,
they all said,
"If you don't get rid of
the threshing machine,
your agony will begin.
We will destroy your machines.
We will burn you out."
But the best that I ever saw
was, "Revenge for thee is
on the wing from thy determined
Captain Swing."
Who was Captain Swing?
He was a sense of popular
justice.
He was what used to be called
the moral economy.
He did not exist.
He should have.
He still should exist.
He did not exist.
But Captain Swing gave this
kind of paramilitary sense to
"We are many.
We are correct.
We are right.
We have God on our side.
We are organized.
We will win."
The subtext is that "Maybe
we better negotiate and see.
Maybe you keep a few machines
around, but we want our jobs
back."
Captain Swing was everywhere.
He was in Kent.
He was in Cambridgeshire.
He was in Devon.
He was in Wiltshire.
He didn't exist,
but he was everywhere,
at least in the popular
imagination.
By the way, the Captain Swing
folks had some allies.
They were the smaller farmers
who couldn't afford the big-time
threshing machines,
and they thought,
"Maybe if they burn the
machines of my ravenous
neighbor,
that wouldn't be the worst
thing in the world."
So, they get moral support from
folks like that.
They spread.
They're in all sorts of places.
Do they win?
Are you kidding?
They lose.
The sheriff comes in a country
that only had a police force
starting in 1829 in London,
that didn't like the idea of
uniformed armies.
That was something the French
and the Spanish had.
They bring their military
contingents and they beat the
hell out of these people.
They put them on trial.
They hang some of them,
not all that many.
They sent lots of them to
Tasmania or to Australia.
"We all live in a convict
colony,"
as they sometimes sing in
Australia whenever they play the
"poms,"
as they sometimes call the
British.
They send them a long,
long way and they defeat them.
It's bitter hard to write the
history of remainders.
It's fun, though, too.
It's fun.
Captain Swing disappears.
The big guys win.
Enclosure keeps rolling along.
Tens of thousands of people are
on the road.
Oh, they get a little victory.
The poor law of 1832 was
probably influenced by this
perceived threat of popular
people voting with their feet,
threatening but also
negotiating, cajoling,
trying to imagine a time in the
past when everybody had a shot
at doing well enough.
The same thing as the grain
riots, imagining a time when
there was a just price for
everything.
Captain Swing was really part
of that.
Obviously, I find what they did
thrilling, but I probably
shouldn't say that.
And, of course,
they probably had a lot of time
to think about what they did on
that extraordinarily long trip
to Port Arthur,
not the Port Arthur in Asia,
but the Port Arthur in
Tasmania,
or to what would become New
South Wales or Victoria in
Australia.
But Captain Swing disappears.
He never existed,
but he sure should have.
A long time ago,
when I was starting out,
I was working in the archives
in Vincennes on the edge of
Paris,
the military archives in the
big Chateau de Vincennes.
I was working on other stuff
and I kept finding these
incidents that were occurring at
precisely the same time as
Captain Swing,
1829-30,
not in England but in France.
I kept finding these reports
from a part of--;I didn't bring
a map and I can't draw worth a
damn either.
Imagine la belle France.
Nice, huh?
Mountains.
Toulouse here.
Bordeaux down here,
voilà.
I kept finding in a department
called the Ariège,
the mountainous department,
I kept finding these reports.
The capital is Foix,
but that's in the plain,
kind of.
Then you go up in the mountains.
You've got real serious
mountains.
Now people drive through those
mountains to get to Andorra,
to buy cheaper pastis,
and cigarettes,
and that kind of thing.
It's very beautiful there.
It's also full now of people
from 1968 who went off and
formed communes in the
Ariège.
Sometimes you'll see some of
them staggering around there.
I kept finding reports from the
police or from the
gendarmes,
above all,
or from mayors saying that men
dressed as women were coming
down the mountain in the mists,
and fog, and snow,
armed with pitchforks,
armed with rifles and were
chasing away two groups of
people: charbonniers,
charcoal burners--forest people
cutting down trees--and forest
guards--those people guarding
the forests employed by the
state,
employed by the rural
bourgeoisie,
or people living in Foix or
Toulouse who owned a lot of land
in the forest,
or by communes if the forests
were communally owned to try to
keep out ordinary people.
These people were coming down
the mountain and taking shots at
them and yelling nasty things to
them,
threatening them with
pitchforks and trying to drive
them away.
And then, they would find notes
saying, "If the forest
guards and the charcoal burners
come back, your agony will
begin.
Signed Jean,
Lieutenant of the
Demoiselles."
A demoiselle in French is
obviously a young woman.
These became known as the
Demoiselles of the
Ariège.
I found so many of these in
1829,1830, 1831,
a few in 1848,
a couple in 1872,
and never again.
Who were these people and what
were they doing?
What they wanted,
again think of Captain Swing
and think of the grain riots,
what they wanted was access to
the forest.
They'd always had access to the
forest.
It's cold in the Ariège.
You need wood that's gleaned
from the forest to make fire to
stay alive.
You need berries, roots to eat.
You need places to pasture your
animals,
pigs which eat right down
through the root,
goats like we have in our
village in Ardèche,
or sheep.
If they're really rich maybe
cows, but that didn't happen
very much there.
The rich guys owned the cows.
The peasants didn't own the
cows.
They'd always,
for centuries as they well
remembered, had access to the
forest.
Why did they lose access to the
forests?
They're looking back at an
imaginary time.
It wasn't imaginary.
They always had had access.
There was lots of forest--the
whole place.
Deforestation is a big problem
in France since the seventeenth
and eighteenth century.
But the Pyrenees have many
forests, many mountains.
They'd always been able to go
there as they wanted.
They didn't own the forest,
but use and property were not
categories that meant anything
to anyone.
They're told they can't go
there anymore.
Some of them go to churches and
they're looking for deeds that
would have given people of those
villages rights to be in the
forest centuries ago.
No.
They don't find them.
So, why can't they go in the
forest anymore to pasture their
miserable animals or to find
something to eat or some fuel?
Why can't they do that anymore?
Aha!
We're talking capitalism in the
state.
The price of wood has increased.
Why?
The metallurgical industry,
what they call Catalan,
as in Catalonia,
forges small metallurgical
industries.
The price of wood goes up.
Suddenly the people that own
the forest say,
"Hey baby,
we don't want those peasants
and their animals in the forest
anymore."
They start hiring forest guards.
They start hiring charcoal
burners,
the charbonniers,
who are chopping down the
trees,
slicing them up,
as people still do in the Jura,
or in the Black Forest,
or do anywhere that you can
think of in Europe.
In Oregon, where I'm from,
logging was a good way to make
money.
I never did it,
but when you're in college.
And, so, the wood is leaving
the forests.
People are getting even richer
and the peasants are out of
luck.
Why are they out of luck?
Because what the big-money
people do that own the forest is
they do exactly what the wealthy
did in England,
the big landowners.
They get the law on their side.
What a surprise.
They have their lobbyists.
They get the law on their side.
They pass a new forest code in
1827 that keeps ordinary people
out of the forests to which they
had always had access.
They always had access.
They can't go there anymore.
They go up there and they find
armed guards there.
They are many and the guards
are few and they scare the hell
out of them and they drive them
away.
The mayors of these little
villages, Massat--I love to go
there.
I've written about it.
Massat was one of the mayors.
He's in a difficult position.
He knows damn well who is
causing the troubles,
les troubles,
in the forests,
but he's got to live with these
people.
He isn't going to be telling on
anybody.
I followed this through.
I read this and wrote something
about it in a book I did a long
time ago called 1830 in
France, an edited book.
So, what happens?
Who is Jeanne,
Lieutenant of the Demoiselles?
Jeanne.
Who is she?
She didn't exist either.
She's exactly like Captain
Swing.
She says, "We are many.
We are right.
We have justice on our
side."
By the way, these people did
not speak French.
It was hard for them to find
somebody to write in French
"Your agony will
begin," because they don't
speak French.
They spoke a patois that's very
much influenced by Spanish
that's not even really like
Catalan and certainly nothing to
do with Basque.
It doesn't have anything to do
with anything except vaguely
Hungarian and Finnish.
They write these things and
they said that Jeanne,
the Lieutenant of the
Demoiselles will toast you one
day if you don't leave the
forests.
What they want is they want the
government to restore their
rights in the forest.
Does the government do that?
Are you kidding?
Of course they don't.
Now, 1830 comes along,
"revolution,
liberty, fraternity,
equality, red,
white, and blue."
What do they do?
They say, "Well,
this liberty must mean that we
can have our forests back,
doesn't it?"
One of the interesting things
about this is they become
petitioners just for a little
bit.
They get people who can write
French to petition saying,
"We hear about this
liberty in Paris.
That surely is our forests,
isn't it?"
Un-uh.
The government says,
"Oh, no.
The Forest Code of 1827 is
evermore in use and you can't
have access to the forest."
The forest guards return.
The forest guards return to the
forest, but so do the
demoiselles.
They begin to dress up as women
again.
They lose.
What a surprise.
They're driven away.
Why do they dress up as women?
One thing they do,
mocking the charcoal workers
also, they put charcoal on their
face and they wear sheets.
They try to make them look like
dresses.
Why as women?
It's more than a disguise.
What it is is an enraged
carnival.
If you think of carnival,
think of Mardi Gras,
anywhere in Christian Europe,
what you do during carnival,
look at the floats in New
Orleans when everybody's getting
wasted and dressing up in
various things.
The old version of that was
that you dressed up like you're
exploiters.
The three or four days you
could mock the judge who handed
out unfair sentences.
You could mock the big fat
noble who had seigneurial rights
over you.
You could mock the
gendarmes,
who you thought treated you
badly.
You could pretend.
It was a carnival,
but an enraged carnival.
During carnival you stand the
world on its head.
What you did in this case is
you dressed up as women,
reversing reality from their
point of view.
This enraged carnival is
intended,
rather like the
charivari,
the shivaree in English,
in which you pound on pots and
pans outside the house of a
couple or a woman,
for example,
who has married somebody from
another village.
You try to set things right
again by pounding and calling
attention to a misdeed that has
violated the communal sense of
justice.
That's what these people are
doing.
They're saying,
"Respect us.
Respect justice."
And, so, they're dressing up
like women.
They're standing the world on
its head.
It's an enraged,
deadly serious carnival.
They'll shoot at these people
and beat the hell out of them
when they catch them.
So, Jean, the lieutenant of the
demoiselles, represents justice
and this kind of acting out of
this enraged carnival.
It's more than a disguise.
But they don't win.
Captain Swing doesn't win,
either.
They're arrested.
They're put on trial.
Some of them are put in jail.
But in the end,
they come back at the end of
1830,1831, some in 1832,
if I remember right,
1848 they're back,
1872, but then never again.
The Ariège as a
department depopulates rapidly
in the second half of the
nineteenth century.
These people can't make it in
the forest anymore.
They can't go into the forest
anymore.
They can't survive with their
little plots of land.
So, they bail out.
They get out.
Their great, great,
great grandchildren,
many of them work in the
aérospatiale,
the aircraft factories in
Toulouse,
or go to Bordeaux,
or go to Paris,
or go to Agen,
or end up somewhere else.
The demoiselles,
like Captain Swing,
like these grain rioters in all
of these countries,
in Spain, in Britain,
in Prussia, everywhere,
these are the remnants of what
people viewed as a traditional
way of doing things that at
least was infused with a sense
of the proper,
a sense of popular justice.
The demoiselles tried to stand
the world on its head during
carnival,
and tried to get people to do
the right thing,
to return the forests to them,
to get the threshing machines
the hell out of the big farms in
Kent and other places,
restore grain and bread to a
reasonable price so everybody
could have a shot at buying
some.
But in the end,
they lose out to this dynamic
duo, this more powerful duo,
the state and capitalism.
It's bitter hard to write the
history of remainders.